I'm a tribe wife. I got married at 18.
My husband is the main breadwinner,
and I'm pregnant with our first child.
What would I do if my husband died?
This question I've been asked many times
from both naysayers and just curious individuals,
people who have been in the same situation before.
And I thought it was about time to answer this in depth.
So welcome to my series on emergency protocols.
I'm gonna share some of the things that we have set up
to make a transition if one of us dies
a little bit easier. Just on an admin side of things.
I hope that this helps you
if you're trying to figure out the same sort of thing.
So first, we are joint on all bank accounts.
I have my own line of credit and a credit score.
We're joint owners on our house and land.
I've access to all of the passwords and email accounts.
We both have life insurance.
It's a small policy,
but it's enough to cover funeral expenses and the cost of moving.
We have an emergency fund and additional savings.
We have a will with final wishes and a designated trustee,
estate manager, someone to handle all of those things.
Chance of both of us dying in a car crash is actually kind of high.
So our cars both transfer on death to my father in law.
And then if just my husband was to die,
then they would get transferred To me,
we always pay bills together,
so I know exactly how to pay bills,
but most of them are on auto pay from a credit card.
If something happened and we forgot to pay a Bill,
it would get paid and the lights would stay on.
Like and follow. For part two,
as we continue talking about emergency protocols. To have